I'm going to go out on a limb here
and guess that you've probably heard
of the Knights Templar. Despite apparently
having apparently been disbanded
getting on for a millennium ago, this
secretive order of Christian warrior monks
remains surprisingly prominent
in the public consciousness,
cropping up in video games, TV shows,
novels, and films with impressive regularity.
Perhaps that has something to do with the
widespread rumours that the Knights Templar
never really went away, and that the remnants of
this secret order continue to pull the strings of
society from the shadows even today. Whatever
the reason, it's clear the Knights Templar
have gotten themselves tangled up with a huge
range of myths and legends over the centuries,
from the holy grail to the ark of the
covenant and the founding of the freemasons.
But as exciting as all these conspiracy
theories are, this is one of those rare
cases where the true story is every bit as
interesting as all the probably-made-up ones.
Because, from incredibly humble beginnings
and in a startlingly short space of time,
the real Knights Templar rose to become one of
the most influential organisations in history.
During their meteoric rise, the Templars
attained unimaginable wealth, broke new
boundaries in the business world, and wielded
the kind of power that makes even kings jealous.
But, as is often the case with rapid rises, the
fall of the Knights Templar was, if anything,
even more spectacular, ending with one of the
most powerful men on earth being burnt at the
stake in the Shadow of Notre Dame cathedral while
spitting curses like Kanye West on a dis track.
But... I'm getting ahead of myself.
To best tell the story of the Knights
Templar, I should probably start
at the beginning - a beginning that can be found
almost a thousand years ago in 1119 AD, exactly
20 years after the Franks captured Jerusalem from
the Fatimid Caliphate during the First Crusade.
With Jerusalem suddenly under Christian
control, Christian pilgrims from across
Europe began flocking to the Holy Land to
visit the many sacred sites found there.
But these pilgrimages were dangerous.
While the city of Jerusalem itself
was well guarded, much of the rest of
the Holy Land - which stretches from
the Mediterranean Sea to the banks of the
river Jordan - wasn't. Bandits were common,
and pilgrims were easy targets.
Thousands were robbed or even killed.
Sickened by this wanton slaughter, a French
knight by the name of Hugues de Payens decided
to transform himself into the hero the Holy
Land needed. So, he gathered together 8 of his
knightly mates, and, with the blessing of King
Baldwin II of Jerusalem, formed a new monastic
order with the sole aim of protecting Christian
pilgrims on their travels around the holy land.
To begin with, that's all it was - a few brave
knights chaperoning pilgrims. Despite having been
given shiny new headquarters on Temple Mount in
Jerusalem by the king himself, the knights were
incredibly poor, relying on the charity of those
they protected to survive. Their lack of funds
(along with the location of the headquarters)
actually inspired their original name - 'The
Poor Knights of the Temple of King Solomon.' But
that was a bit of a mouthful, and so eventually
it was shortened to the name that remains
so famous even today - the Knights Templar.
This small band of warrior monks did
their protection job exceptionally well,
and soon enough their reputation in Christendom
began to grow, helped in no small part by the
fact that one of the original knights had a nephew
who was going places in the catholic church. And
when I say he was going places, he was eventually
made a saint - when he talked, Catholics listened.
Before long, the Knights Templar were the
trendiest charity in town, and anyone who
was anyone suddenly wanted to be seen to be
supporting them. Some donated cold hard cash,
others left land or valuables to the Templars in
their wills, and noble families started sending
any spare male sons they had lying around to
join the order and make a name for themselves.
By 1135 AD, even the Pope was feeling a bit
of FOMO, which he quenched by issuing the
Templars with a large monetary donation.
4 years later, he passed a Papal order
that made the Templars exempt from paying taxes
and essentially put them outside of local law in
whichever countries they operated in - in short,
they were answerable only to the Pope himself.
From there, the power and popularity
of the Templars continued to snowball.
At their peak, there were thought to be as many as
20,000 members spread across pretty much
the whole of Europe and the Middle East.
But the Templars never let this success
go to their heads. The life of a knight
was heavily regimented and restricted. All new
inductees were made to take vows of poverty,
chastity, piety, and obedience. They also
had to follow several hundred strict rules
that dictated how they should
lead their day to day lives.
These rules were incredibly prescriptive,
outlining what the knights could eat,
how they should spend their free time, and
what they could wear. Most importantly of all,
the rules made it clear that the Knights were
to avoid fraternising with women at all costs.
All that pent up sexual frustration seems to
have paid off, because the Knights had a truly
fearsome reputation on the battlefields of the
Holy Land. They excelled to such an extent that
they evolved from pilgrim protectors to an
elite corps of heavily armoured shock troops
that were deployed wherever the fighting
was fiercest throughout the crusades.
The knights were well trained and expensively
armed, but it was their bravery that really
stood out - they were forbidden from retreating
in battle unless every single Templar flag on the
field had fallen. It helped that dying
in battle was seen as a great honour,
granting the fallen knight automatic queue jump
privileges at the gates of heaven. As a result,
the Templars showed no fear even
in the most hopeless situations.
Away from the battlefields of the Holy Land,
things were going equally well for the Order,
which had become so rich so quickly it
hardly knew what to do with all the cash.
Eventually, the Templars settled
on basically doing everything.
Real estate was one of the biggest focuses,
and as well as buying up huge swathes of land
in Europe and the Middle East, they built
castles and cathedrals by the hundreds,
many of which still stand to this day.
They bought up vineyards, farmland,
and stables, got involved in manufacturing,
and hired blacksmiths, builders and squires.
They also bought a large fleet of ships, and,
most impressively of all, the entire island
of Cyprus. Off the back of these achievements
and more, some modern historians consider
the Knights Templar to have been the
world's first multinational corporation.
One of the most successful aspects of
this business empire was dedicated to
what can be considered a prototype of the
modern concept of international banking.
The system started out as an innovative way to
help Christians with the logistics of visiting
the Holy Land. A pilgrim could head to a Templar
house in their home country before setting off
to hand over valuables or cash in return for
a letter of credit. That credit could then be
'withdrawn' from any other Templar
house anywhere else in the world.
It was actually kind of ingenious. Not only did
it give the Templars another way to make money,
it also helped them with their original mission
of protecting Christians in the Holy Land. Since
pilgrims no longer had to carry valuables
with them on their trip to Jerusalem,
they became far less attractive to bandits.
Over time, the financial services offered by
the Templars expanded to include the pawning
of valuables, money lending, and even the
paying of ransoms on credit. These services
were so highly regarded they were used by some of
the most powerful people in Europe at the time,
including at least two kings - King Henry III of
England is said to have pawned his Crown Jewels
with the Templars in order to raise some quick
cash to help quell an uprising among his Barons,
and King Philip IV of France borrowed
significant sums from the Templars
to finance a series of expensive wars, mostly
with the English (it was always the English).
Somehow, in under 200 years,
what had started out as 9
poverty-stricken knights protecting
pilgrims on the road to Jerusalem
had somehow grown into a multinational
conglomerate with the power of a small country.
The trouble was, while the Templars had the riches
and influence of a nation, they didn’t actually
control one. And that meant their entire existence
relied on the goodwill of the men who did - the
kings of Europe. Unfortunately for the Templars,
that goodwill was about to abruptly run out.
It started with the fall of Jerusalem to
legendary general Saladin and his armies in 1187.
The Christians did manage to regain the city again
in 1229, but they lost it again 15 years later.
Jerusalem would remain under Muslim
control for the next 700 years.
The Templars had diversified admirably
in the years since their foundation,
but at their core, they existed to
fight for Christianity in the Holy Land.
With that land now under new ownership,
for the first time since their formation,
people began to question whether or not the
Knights Templar were really necessary anymore.
By this point they should have been
big enough and powerful enough to
shrug that kind of criticism off.
And they probably would have done,
had their own success not come back to
bite them at the worst possible time.
I mentioned a moment ago that Philip
IV of France had borrowed money from
the Templars to fight the English. What I didn't
mentioned is that he'd borrowed a *lot* of money.
So much, in fact, that paying it all back
was proving to be a bit of a problem.
Luckily for Philip IV, he was a king.
And kings have always had their own unique ways of
dealing with problems - usually by murdering them.
Seizing on the shifting public
sentiment towards the Templars,
King Philip put together a list of heresies he
claimed were being committed by the secretive
Templars in their castles and cathedrals. Those
heresies included spitting and urinating on the
Cross, worshipping false idols, specifically
Baphomet, and engaging in homosexual activities.
It was mostly bullshit obviously - well,
apart from that last one. You can't build
a secret order of 20,000 men who are
forbidden to fraternise with women
without things getting at least
a little bit Brokeback Mountain.
But King Philip wasn't worried about the
veracity of his claims. All he had to do
was find a few prominent Templars willing to
confess to the crimes they were accused of
and his case would be watertight. And no Templars
were more prominent than Jacques de Molay,
Grand Master and leader of the entire order.
You might think it would be difficult to get
the brave Knights Templar to admit to crimes
they hadn't committed, but remember - this was
a time long before trifling things like human
rights existed. If you were a king and you wanted
someone to confess to something they didn't do,
all you had to do was them torture
them for a bit and you were golden.
Sure enough, Jacques de Molay - along
with many of his knights - confessed
to everything. Many would later recant their
confessions once free of the thumbscrews,
but by then it was too late. The
Templar name had been tarnished, and,
under pressure from King Philip, the Pope
instructed that every Templar in Europe
should be arrested and put on trial. A few
years later, the order was officially disbanded.
Hundreds, perhaps thousands of
Templars were killed for their
supposed crimes, including Jacques de Molay,
who King Philip had burned at the stake on an
island in the middle of the River Seine in Paris.
It's said that Molay cursed both the Pope and
King Philip even as the flames ate him alive,
vowing that divine retribution would
be brought down on them both in short
order. And it seems the guy knew
how to execute a solid curse,
because both the Pope and King
Philip were dead within the year.
Not that it made any difference for the
Templars. Their race was officially run.
Those that escaped persecution joined other
catholic military orders or simply retired,
never to raise arms again in the name of God.
Or at least, that's the official line.
But of course, plenty of people believe
the Templars never truly went away. As for
why that is... well, that's a good question,
and there's no simple answer. In truth, there's
little evidence to support pretty much any of the
many myths and legends that surround the Templars
today. When the organisation was disbanded,
it left behind a huge void, and over the years
people have filled that void with stories.
Many of the myths are linked to the mystery
of what happened to the Templar's vast
wealth after their demise, but there's actually
a pretty simple answer to that one - King
Philip the IV happened to it, appropriating
Templar funds to pay off his mountainous debts.
Most other European kings did the same.
These days, many people and organisations
around the world claim to be descendants
of the Knights Templar - including the
Freemasons - but almost all of them are
just appropriating the Templar story because
it sounds cool.The vast majority of so-called
'Knights Templar' knocking around today are just
middle-aged men with overactive imaginations
who think they look good in chainmail.
That isn't quite the end of the story though.
Because there is actually one modern organisation
that genuinely is linked to the Templars - the
Military Order of Christ based in Portugal.
You see, while the various kings of
Europe were arresting Templars left
right and centre by order of the Pope, one
king - Denis of Portugal - refused. Instead,
he set up the Military Order of Christ and
invited any surviving ex Templars to join.
The group still exists today more than 700 years
later, but sadly there's no reason to believe
they're hiding the Holy Grail, the Ark of the
Covenant, or Jesus and Mary Magdalene's great,
great, great, great, great, great grandchildren
(sorry to disappoint you Dan Brown).
The Templar's legacy lives on in other ways
though, too. They did so much building at
the height of their power that many
Templar landmarks still exist today.
Temple, the legal district in
London, is named for the Templars,
along with literally hundreds of churches and
castles throughout Europe and the Middle East.
The Templars may be gone, at least in their
original form, but they certainly haven’t been
forgotten. And if you ask me, the countless myths
and conspiracy theories that surround the order
are surplus to requirements - the
actual documented history of these
warrior monks is better than most of them anyway.
Thanks for watching.